it will be tempted by the dark side hey
youtubers it's Charlie so big Star Wars
7 update they just announced casting for
7 new roles and I have a list here that
I'll read off that'll tell you a little
bit about what they're gonna be doing in
the movie late female independent good
sense of humor fit young 20-something
male witty and smart fit but not
traditionally good-looking a late
twenty-something male fit handsome and
confident 70-something male with strong
opinions and a tough demeanor also
doesn't need to be particularly fit a
second young female also late teens
tough smart and fit 40-something male
fit military-type 30-something male
intellectual apparently doesn't need to
be fit so a lot of people think that
those two late teenage characters are
actually the solo twins Jacen and Jaina
the Jedi twins from the expanded
universe I'm actually inclined to
believe that they're not going to be
including a lot of expanded universe
material in the movie I'll talk about
that a little bit later but now let's
talk about some of the other characters
so remember in the original Star Wars
trilogy Luke Skywalker was a teenager in
the first film I think he's about 18
somebody might be able to correct me on
this but basically this is a movie for
kids not like the George Lucas prequels
as they were for like really little kids
but this was gonna be a really young
cast with a few exceptions that means
that a lot of these 20-somethings and
teenage characters will probably either
be Jedi trainees or just Jedi hopefuls
who have an affinity for the force and
are looking to become Jedi's so we
already know that this movie is going to
take place after the events of the
Battle of Endor and it's going to take
place inside this universe that George
Lucas created despite what they might
change about the story so even if they
do use some of the expanded universe
content it's not going to be like Star
Trek where JJ Abrams just completely
rebooted the series with another prequel
if you think about it that way that old
character is probably a Jedi Master the
70-something character that means
there's a group of people at least a few
of them are actually going to be cast
together as a group that's not
necessarily true but it makes sense the
matically especially if they're trying
to film a lot of scenes with those
characters together they want to get
them on set
soon as possible just so you can see how
their chemistry works together remember
they're starting to film in early 2014
so they actually will probably have most
of the cast by the end of the year and
if you think about it in this George
Lucas universe logically even if they
don't include the events after the
expanded universe started spinning out
stories logically Luke Skywalker would
still be trying to rebuild the Jedi
Order raise your hand if you think we're
gonna see Luke Skywalker inside a
holocron that's right even though
they've signed the original cast to come
back that doesn't mean that they're
going to appear on set I'm guessing that
that forty-something character is not
going to be a Jedi he's going to take
the place that Han Solo would occupy in
the story and they're probably gonna try
and groom him for this new trilogy
hopefully he'll be just as good of a
scoundrel as Harrison Ford was I'm also
guessing that that other character will
be a politician just because it
describes them as being very smart and
out of shape and that kind of describes
most politicians one of the strange
things about this though is the absence
of any female adult characters remember
this is a JJ Abrams movie and most of
his movies even though they might be
really nostalgic and wistful oh isn't it
being really positive in the end think
of super 8 even though it was a little
bit dark and a little bit depressing at
times it ended on a really positive note
so I think that's what this Star Wars
movie is going to be like it's not gonna
be a really awful depressing movie
you're gonna walk away feeling very
hopeful about the series when we get
back to the subject of expanded universe
stories I get a little skeptical just
because when you start working in other
writers stories are working with
characters that were created by other
people you start to get a lot of cooks
in the kitchen and movie studios and
directors like to keep things as simple
as possible so we could totally see some
expanded universe characters like marge
8 or the solo twins in the movie but
it's a really small chance but let me
know what you think are we gonna see the
solo twins are we gonna see any expanded
universe content I don't think we're
gonna see thron but let me know what you
think just write below in the comments I
think Michael Arndt is a really great
writer and JJ Abrams is really good at
making movies so whatever ends up
happening I'm really hopeful about the
movie and I'm excited to see it I don't
think it'll be too gratuitous and even
though JJ Abrams has said many times
that he doesn't play for fans
I do think there'll be a lot of Easter
eggs that everyone can enjoy I'll be
posting casting updates and spoilers as
they come along
be doing that for the rest of this
year's they start filming in the early
2014 be sure to subscribe to get all
those videos it's gonna be really
exciting finding out how this movie's
gonna unfold and once we learn about the
cast we can start to guess about the
kind of story that they're trying to
craft in the meantime I just posted a
big update for the Fifty Shades of Grey
movie even if you're not a total pervert
you should check it out click here to
watch it or you can click here to watch
my first legend of korra book 2 video
I'll be doing videos for that all year
too so get excited thanks for watching
high five
you